اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء اصدر التجمع
اليمني للاصلاح بيانا اكد فيه فشل التواصل
المباشر مع الحوثيين
وطالب هم بسحب مسلحيهم كما رفض فيه قرارات
الرئيس منصور هادي بتعيين محافظين جدد
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقشه في محورين
هل يعتبر هذا البيان نقطه تحول في طريقه
التعامل للاصلاح مع الوضع الحالي في اليمن
وما هي البدائل المتاحه امام حزب الاصلاح
اذن اعلن حزب التجمع اليمني للاصلاح فشل
التواصل المباشر مع جماعه الحوثي كما اعلن
رفضه لقرارات الرئيس اليمني بتعيين
محافظين جدد كان حزب الاصلاح قد تجنب منذ
بدايه تمدد الحوثيين على الارض وسيطرتهم
على العاصمه صنعاء تجنب الدخول في مواجهه
مسلحه معهم معتبرا ان ذلك مؤامره داخليه
وخارجيه ضده على حد وصف قادته
فشل الاصلاح في التواصل المباشر مع
الحوثيين
هكذا اعلنها حزب التجمع اليمني للاصلاح
صراحه ليضع حدا لانتقادات كثير من اعضاء
حزبه ومن المراقبين السياسيين الخطوه التي
اقدم عليها بالتواصل مع جماعه الحوثي فلم
يكد يجف حبر البيان الذي اصدره الطرفان
الجماعه والحزب بعد لقاء القياديين في
الاصلاح غير الشامي و سعيد شمسان ب عبد
الملك الحوثي في صعده حتى ذهب الحوثيون
الى ارحب التي تعد معقلا ل قيادات قبليه
تتبع حزب الاصلاح واستهدفوا منازل تابعه
لهم ومقار ومؤسسات تابعه للحزب ما حدا
بالقياده الاصلاحي زيد الشامي الى التبرؤ
والاعتذار من رحلته الى صعده قائلا ان
الحوثيين غير جادين مقدما الاعتذار لمن
هاجمه واستنكروا مشاركته في تلك اللقاءات
معترفا انهم كانوا على صواب في عدم ثقتهم
بما سموه
نيات الاخرين
بعض قيادي حزب الاصلاح راوا انهم قد نجحوا
في تجنب مؤامره خارجيه وداخليه استهدفت
الحزب عندما لم يدخل في مواجهات مسلحه
متوقعه مع الحوثيين خلال تمدد هم في صنعاء
ومناطق اخرى الا انه بعد هذا الموقف وجد
نفسه امام سيناريوهات لا يستطيع التعامل
معها فهو لايستطيع المشاركه في حرب قد
يكون لها اثارها الطائفيه والمذهبيه
منفردا وسط جاهزيه عسكريه كبيره من قبل
الحوثيين المتحالفين مع ايران والرئيس
المخلوع علي عبد الله صالح الذي يريد
الانتقام من الحزب الذي شارك في الاطاحه
به في ثوره فبراير الفين واحد عشر كما لا
يستطيع ان يحجز مقعدا منفردا في المعارضه
ضد رئيس هادي او ضد السيطره الحوثيه خاصه
وانه احد الكيانات التي وقعت على المبادره
الخليجيه واليتها التنفيذيه
والبيان الذي اصدره الاصلاح مؤخرا كما
يبدو اراد تحديد مسارات جديده للحزب الذي
وجد نفسه فجاه مرتبكا المشهد اليمني
المرتبط برمته الذي افرزته سلطه ضعيفه و
جماعه مسلحه ونظام مخلوع يتربص وعجز
اقليمي ودولي عن تشخيص الموقف ووضع اليات
لوقف النزيف
الحوثيون ا عجزوا كل فعل سياسي ب سيطرتهم
المسلحه وانتهاكاتهم المتواصله واستهدافهم
للدوله والمعارضين وخاصه حزب الاصلاح وم
قاره وشخوصه ومناطق كما يقود الاصلاح في
بياناته الاخيره والرئيس هادي لم يعد
صديقه الحزب بعد ان دارت اتهامات في وسائل
الاعلام باشتراكه في مؤامره لاستهداف
الحزب وهو ما حدا به لوصف قراراته الاخيره
الخاصه بتعيين محافظين جدد ينتمي معظمهم
للحوثيين وحزب صالح بانها استمرار لعمليه
الاقصاء بالقوى السياسيه لصالح جماعات
العنف المسلح وانتهاك صارخ لسائر
الاتفاقات التي تحكم المرحله فهل قرر
الحزب السياسي الاكبر الذي كان يخرج
ملايين ه في ساحه الثوره عام الفين واحد
عشر تحت شعار السلميه عدم الانخراط في
العنف الذي فجره الحوثيون بمساعده الرئيس
المخ ام انه لابد من اجراء اصلاحات جذريه
في قيادته ورؤيته تغير من طريقه تعامله مع
الموقف الحالي يرى مراقبون ان الاصلاح قد
واتته اللحظه وشركائه الوطنيين بلعب دور
المعارض من خارج المؤسسات الحكوميه
وهيئاتها من مقاعد الشعب بكتلته الوطنيه
او المنظمه ل سحب البساط من تحت جماعه
الحوثي الحاكم الجديد ليتحول الحزب
وشركائه الوطنيون من رد الفعل الى الفعل
نفسه
موضوع حلقتنا هذا نناقشه مع ضيوفنا من
صنعاء سعيد شمسان رئيس الدائره السياسيه
والناطق الرسمي باسم التجمع اليمني
للاصلاح
ومن صنعاء ايضا القيادي في جماعه انصار
الله الحوثيين محمد السراجي سنحاول مع
ضيفينا من صنعاء اه
سنحاول النقاش والوقوف على طبيعه المواقف
الصادره لكلا الجامعتين حزب الاصلاح
وجماعه انصار الله الحوثيين لكن يبدو ان
مشكله في الصوت
موجوده الان سنحاول تفادي هذه المشكله ثم
نعود ل اه
متابعه هذه الحلقه واه النقاش مع ضيفينا
من صنعاء ابقوا معنا مشاهدينا
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه الحلقه والتي
نناقش فيها موضوع فشل الحوار بين حزب
الاصلاح اليمني وجماعه الحوثي
اه معنا اه سعيد شمسان رئيس الدائره
السياسيه والناطق الرسمي باسم التجمع
اليمني للاصلاح وايضا محمد السراجي
القيادي في جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين
ابدا معك سيد اه سيراج ي اه اسباب فشل
الحوار واضحه في اه بيان التجمع اليمني
للاصلاح انتم لم تهيء اجواء الحوار لم
تكون جديين كان المنتظر منكم ان اه تعيد
ما نهب من ممتلكات و مقرات الحزب لكن كل
هذا لم يحصل لا بل استمر الحوثيون بتفجير
اه مقرات حزب الاصلاح لماذا فعلتم ذلك و
افشلتم الحوار
الرحمن الرحيم الحمدلله رب العالمين وصلى
الله وسلم على سيدنا محمد وعلى اله
الطيبين الطاهرين ورضي الله عن اصحابه
المنتجبين
اه اولا ابارك للامتين العربيه والاسلاميه
قدم ذكرى مولد النبي صلى الله عليه وعلى
اله وسلم وبعض اه بالنسبه لسؤالك الذي
تفضلت فيه وتشعبت في اه طرحه من انصار
الله اه افشلوا ال الحوار ولم ينفذوا
وتعنتوا هذا كلام غير صحيح على الاطلاق
اه انصار الله اه يمدون ايديهم ومدوا
ايديهم واه استقبال السيد عبد الملك بدر
الدين الحوثي
العديد من قيادات الاخوه في التجمع اليمني
للاصلاح
وما خرجوا به كان اه يعني اه رؤيه واضحه
وكان اه بادره حسن نيه واثبات حسن نيه من
قبل انصار الله انهم يريدون ان يعيشوا
يتعايشوا مع كل الفرقاء في الجمهوريه
اليمنيه بالنسبه لقضيه المقرات
على من الاصلاح هذا الكلام غير صحيح انصار
الله واللجان الشعبيه اه اه قامت بتسليم
الاقوى بالتجمع اليمني للاصلاح اه يعني
كافه المقرات التي
لم تقابل مع المجرم الهارب علي محسن
الاحمر من داخل تلك المقرات اما بالنسبه
لكافه المقرات تم تسلمها من قبل انصار
الله واللجان الشعبيه كامله بمحاضر رسميه
بوجودها اشراف وسائل الاعلام المختلفه
سيد شمس ان ما رايك بما ذكره السيد
السياسي والذي ينسى فيه ما جاء في بيان
حزب التجمع اليمني للاصلاح من اسباب فشل
الحوار
اه بسم الله الرحمان الرحيم شكرا جزيلا
وانا اود ان اقول للاخ محمد السراجي ان
هناك كثير من مقرات التجمع اليمني للاصلاح
لم يتم تسليمها ولم تكن فعلا اه كما اشار
انه ال ال المقررات التي واجهت الحوثيين ب
اه عند ارتياحهم الى صنعاء انا اقول واؤكد
ان هناك عشرات المقرات ما زالت حتى هذه
اللحظه لم تسلم الينا رغم الوعود المتكرره
منذ عودتنا من الصعداء بعد لقاء الاخ عبد
الملك الحوثي الى هذه اللحظه مقرات بامانه
العاصمه مقراتنا في عمران مقرات نافيه الى
هذه اللحظه لا رغم الوعود المتكرره من قبل
اخواننا في قياده ال اه الحوثيين الا انها
لم تسلم حتى هذه اللحظه واؤكد ها سلمنا
كشفا بها الاخ عبد الملك الحوتي وسلمنا
ايضا كشفا بها للاخ ممثل عبد الملك الحوتي
بامانه العاصمه
ووعدنا مرارا بانهم سيسلمون وفي اخر
اللقاء كان بيننا هي يوم السبت الماضي
وعدني بان خلال يومين او ثلاثه ايام سيتم
تسليم تلك المقرات الا انه لم يتم شيئا من
ذلك حتى هذه اللحظه هل هذا هو السبب
الرئيس والجوهري في وقف الحوار وفشله
اعتقد بان هناك قضايا كثيره كانت سبب في
اخفاق كما جاء في بيان الامانه العامه
للتجمع ال من الاصلاح اخفاق في عمليه
التواصل بيننا والاخوه الحوثيين منها
الانتهاكات التي طالت مقراتنا وقياداتنا
واعضائنا سواء في ارحب او في غيرها من
المحافظات الاخرى وغيرها من الانتهاكات
التي طالت الناشطين السياسيين والاعلاميين
على مختلف الصعد كل تلك الاحداث
والتجاوزات كانت سبب ذلك الاخفاق الذي تم
بيننا وبين الاخوه اه حقيقه لم نشعر ان
هناك جديه رغم التواصل المستمر من قبلنا
مع الاخوه الحوثيين لكننا وجدنا هناك
تباطؤ وجدنا هناك تلك وجدنا هناك تخلف عما
تم الاتفاق عليه والبدء بتنفيذ انا اعتقد
ان القضيه ما زال هناك فرصه مواتيه
لمواصله ما بداناه لكن هذا يتطلب فعلا
جديه ومصداقيه وتنفيذ لما تم الاتفاق عليه
وخاصه في التوقف الفوري الاعتداءات
والانتهاكات الناشطين والاعلاميين
والمؤسسات الاعلاميه والممتلكات الخاصه
والعامه وانتهاك وتفجير تذكير المقرات هل
فعلا يمكن واحد يقبله باي تحت اي مبرر
كثير المنازل
لان هناك كثير من
العراقيين بدليل ما ذكره اه السيد شمس او
هو اشار الى الكثير من الانتهاكات واه
الممارسات وبالتالي ربما لم يكن هناك صدق
من الحوثيين في الوصول الى نتيجه في هذا
الحوار
لا لا ليس ربما لم يكن هنالك ربما لم
يستوعب الكثيرين ولما ي يدرك الكثيرين
الحقيقه الاستاذ سعيد وقعنا معهم اتفاقيه
السلم الشراكه باسم انصار الله وليس باسم
الحوثيين اما بالنسبه لما يقول ان رجال
الدين وقضيه التفجيرات وغيرها وما حصل في
ارهاب انا اقول لك على التجمع اليمني
للاصلاح ان يثبت حسن نيته
موقف الصريح والواضح من العمليات
التفجيريه التي تطال ابناء اليمن وابناء
الشعب وبالنسبه لل مقرات او ال الاماكن او
البيوت التي يتم تفجيرها الاخوه في التجمع
اليمني للاصلاح
لماذا يتسترون عن من يقوم بتصريح العبوات
الناسفه والمفخخات لقتل ابناء اليمن قتل
اطفال اليمن
لماذا لم يوضع السيد شمس ان اه ماذا ترد
على هذه النقطه بالتحديد نعم
على كل حال انا اقول بانه نتحدى اخواننا
الحوثيين ان يقولوا ان هناك مقر من مقرات
ان فيها متفجرات
والتكفيريين نتحداهم انه يجب ان منزلا
واحدا من منازل قياداتنا التي فجرها انها
كانت فعلا مع والتكفيريين التي يدعون
يدعونها انا اقول ما حصل في اه الرداء كان
هو بين القبائل وبين ال الاخوه الحوثيين
الذين جاؤوا من صعده بالهجوم على اخواننا
من ابناء محافظه البيضاء
انا اعتقد ان هذه التخصصات التي تقولها
الاخوه الحوثيون غير صادقه ونتحداهم ان
يثبتوا حاله واحده
قلنا نتحاور
الموضوع على بساط البحث الموضوع متشعب جدا
وهناك اسباب
اه يعني اه اصلها عدم وجود ثقه حقيقيه
فقدان الثقه بينكم وبين الحوثيين لم ندخل
كثيرا في موضوع الاسباب نريد ان نسال عن
ما هو قادم في ظل فشل الحوار لكن قبل ذلك
اه معنا عبر الهاتف الدكتور فارس السقاف
مستشار الرئيس اليمني لشؤون الاستراتيجيه
مرحبا بك سيد فارس واه اريد ايضا موقفا
منكم ما ورد من اتهامات للرئيس منصور
عبدربه منصور هادي فيما يتعلق ب اه
بعدم جديته ايضا
بما سمي بين هلالين تامر على اه التجمع
اليمني للاصلاح وموضوع ال اه المحافظين
السبع تعيين المحافظين السبعه القريبين من
جماعه الحوثي تفضل
اه في اعتقادي ان التوقف الان عنده قوه
تعيينات الاخيره واعتبارها اس الاشتراك او
من دواعي فرض عقد الشراكه ليس دقيقا
المشكله هي متنازع سلطتين الان سلطه شرعيه
توافقيه يمثلها الرئيس عبد ربه منصور هادي
وسلطه الامر الواقع التي يمثلها الحوثيون
السلطه الشرعيه
افرزت حكومه كفاءات التزمت بتقديم ادائها
كل ثلاثه اشهر يعني التعيينات وفق تطوير
اه للرئيس لرئيس الحكومه اه لكن في
المقابل هناك سلطه الامر الواقع
تفضل قراراتها بانها كل مظاهر الدوله وهو
ما تندد من السلطه الشرعيه والقوى
السياسيه بما فيها التجمع اليمني للاصلاح
هذا خلل كبير ما يجب ان يستمر لابد من
مراجعه اتفاقا في المشتركه اما ما يتعلق
بالتعليمات الاخيره فرضتها اعتباره عده
اولا انها جاءت لمعالجه اوضاع مقتله وقتيه
لا يمكن تاجيلها اكثر من ذلك وهو يستند
الرئيس في ذلك الى صلاحيات الرئيس
الدستوريه وهي محصوره وزارات سياديه وجود
الرئيس فيها وهي تمثل بدواعي الرئيس يراعي
المكونات السياسيه
عفوا انت تشير الى سلطه الامر الواقع الا
تؤثر سلطه الامر الواقع الان في قرارات اه
الرئيس
ومنها تعيين المحافظين السبعه
لا ليست
محافظه عدم مثلا كما قلت هناك فراغ في
موقع المحافظ المهارات و في المحافظه جاء
استجابه للمجلس المحلي في واقع غير طبيعي
منذ ان الجهات معالجه متنازع بين الاحزاب
الحوثيين الشراكه لا يجب ان تقدم الى
محافظه لا تعني المحافظه
ضرب مفتوحه الوطن من اثاره ضيقه الشراكه
لابد ان ت لابد ان يقع
الاتفاق الى طاوله الحوار والمكاشفه ما
نفذ
هناك اتهامات للرئيس اليمني بانه لا يحرك
ساكنا ازاء وجود سلطه الامر الواقع وما
تمارسه سلطه الامر الواقع على الارض وكان
هناك اتفاق خفي بينه
وبين الحوثيين وربما هذا ما يخشى التجمع
اليمني للاصلاح
هل من المتوقع من الرئيس ان يواجه الحرب
ولدينا اتفاق واضح اتفاق شرعي واتفاق
السلم والشراكه الوطنيه وقع عليه جميع
المكونات السياسيه والدته القوى الاقليميه
والدوليه والمجتمع الدولي اذن ينبغي
الرجوع الى هذه الاتفاقيه
ومراجعتها
لمن يحب الالتزامات لا بد انا اعتقد اننا
استبشرنا ب بدايه وانطلاق جديده من هذا
الاتفاق لكن يبدو ان التعاطي الاعلامي
الان والخطاب السياسي نريد ان يلقي
باللائمه هنا وهناك وبدلا من ان يعقد
اجتماعا يتلاومون فيه ويراجعون اتفاق
السمو الشراكه الوطنيه اليوم ون الرئيس
الرئيس هذه يتحمل المسؤوليه الان بمناسبه
المكونات السياسيه
لابد ان يكون هناك موقف الرئيس هذه في
مهمه انقاذيه استثنائيه لاتزال البلاد في
مامن من الانهيار الكامل لم ينقطع
الرجوع والرجعه بسبب عدم الذهاب الى
اتضح اتضحت الفكره اشكرك جزيلا على هذه
المشاركه واعود الى ضيفي سيد شمس ان اه
الان حزب التجمع اليمني للاصلاح
ليس صديقا للرئيس عمليا هو اوقف الحوار مع
اه انصار الله بالتالي هل هذا
يعتبر نقطه تحول في استراتيجيه عمل حزب
التجمع اليمني وفي اي اتجاه
لابد من توضيح لقضيه معينه نحن لم نوقف
حوارنا مع الاخوه الحوثيين نحن حقيقه اه
نتواصل اه معهم وكان اخر اتصال كما اشرت
في ال ال ال اه قبل قليل اه يوم السبت
الماضي وكان هناك اتصال يوم امس مع الممثل
ال الاخ عبد الملك الحوثي وطلبنا منه ال
ال ال التنفيذ ال الالتزام الذي تم بخصوص
المقرات والمنازل والمؤسسات والمنشات اه
لكن اه اريد ان نصحح ايضا قضيه اخرى للاخ
فارس السقاف نقول له بانه ال ال المساله
يمكن ان تحل ببساطه جدا وكنا قد دعونا
الاخ رئيس الجمهوريه في بيان سابق بان
يدعوت المكونات الموقعه على مخرجات الحوار
الوطني وتسلم شراكه وان يتشاوروا كما جاء
نص عليه سواء في مخرجه الحر الوطنيه او في
اتفاق السلم الشراكه ان يتشاوروا في مجمل
القضايا المتعلقه في القرارات والتعيينات
او القضايا المتعلقه بالدستور ونهايه
الوطنيه الامه على تنفيذ مخرجات الحوار
الوطني بمعنى اخر نحن نريد فعلا ان يتم
هذا اللقاء وعلى جناح السرعه حتى لا تتازم
الامور ولا تتعقد ولا تذهب المسارات في اه
التعقيد يمكن ان
انتم مطالبون بتنفيذ اتفاق السلم والشراكه
انتم مطالبون بابداء حسن النيه ازاء اه
الاطراف التي اعلنت محاولات حزب التجمع
اليمني للاصلاح انتم مطالبون بوقت
الممارسات والانتهاكات الموجوده على الارض
من قبل انصار الله فبالتالي لماذا
تتعاملون مع الواقع انما لكم لكم ولغيركم
لكم واذا بقي شيء فهو لغيركم
الكلام غير صحيح نحن جادون
ونطالب دائما
وصادقون ولدينا تاكيدات قويه جدا نطالب
الجميع بضروره تنفيذ ما تم الاتفاق عليه
في اتفاق السلم الشراكه ان من يتوصل
ويحاول ان يتملص من تنفيذ ما تم الاتفاق
عليه اه يعني كان واضحا من خلال التعيينات
التي
خرجت وتريد ان تنقلب على تعرف مسار
الاتفاق للسلم الشراكه اما بالنسبه لقضيه
الممارسات هل يريدون او يريد العالم ان
نسقط في وجه ان يقتل الاطفال ويذبح ابناء
اليمن يسمع المتفجرات والمفخخات سواء في
رحاب او في اي مكان اخر نحن ندعو كافه
المكونات والاحزاب ليكونوا صادقين وواضحين
اه وتقول حسن النيه بضروره تنفيذ ما تم
الاتفاق عليه
يقول ب انسحابكم من العاصمه صنعاء ثوره
تشكيل الحكومه وهذا ما حصل ولم يتم
الانسحاب
نحن نحن نحن نحن لم نحصل صنعاء اصلا اه م
نحافظ على الامن والاستقرار في ظل انهيار
امني والانهيار التام الذي تعرضت له من
خلال اه تخلي وهروب من كان ومتنفذين و
مسيطرون على كل المفاصل في صنعاء في امانه
العاصمه ابناء الشعب اللجان الشعبيه حافظت
على ممتلكات الشعب وعلى المواطنين وعلى
الامن والاستقرار ووضعت مبدا السلم
والحقيقه ليتم التنفيذ يقدمون ويكون
صادقين يتم تنفيذ
ثلاثه
بانتظار متفاعلون عذرا
عذرا سيد سيرجي اه بانتظار بانتظار سيد
شمس ان بانتظار اه يعني اه تحقق اه
الاجتماع المقبل او اجتماع اليمنيين من
اجل اه تنفيذ اتفاق سلم والشراكه الان ما
هي البدائل المتاحه امام حزب التجمع
اليمني للاصلاح العوده الى الحوار مجددا
ام تغيير استراتيجيه التعامل على الارض
يعني مواجهه بمعنى المواجهه بالتاكيد
في الاتجاهين
الحوار لان الحوار لا يمكن ان نقفز عليه
فهو الوسيله الوحيده الممكنه ال المتاحه
بين الاطراف اليمنيه والمكونات السياسيه
وعلى الجميع ان يتحمل مسؤولياته
الانتماء الوطني
والان الحوار فشل ماهي شروط استئناف
ليس هناك شروط بقد ما نقول للاخ رئيس
الجمهوريه ان يدعو خلال اربعه وعشرين ساعه
المكونات السياسيه للوقوف على جميع ال ال
النقاط الوارده في اتفاق الشراكه الحوار
الوطني وان يتم الاعلان عن كل من يتجاوز
او يتنصر او يقفز على هذه المخرجات وعلى
ما وردت اتفاق السلم الشراكه ونريد هناك
جدول زمني
لتحقيق ذلك واعلان اه ال ال ال الموضوع
للراي العام انا اقول انه الشفافيه
والوضوح التعاطي مع هذه القضايا هو
الوسيله ال ال ال ال مثلا تجاوز العقبات
التي حصلت اه في المرحله السابقه هذا ما
ينبغي ان يتم خلال الساعات القادمه اشكرك
جزيلا سعيد شمسان رئيس الدائره السياسيه
والمنطق الرسمي التجمع اليمني للاصلاح
واشكر محمد سيرجي القيادي في جماعه انصار
الله الحوثيين كنت ما معنا من صنعاء بهذا
مشاهدينا تنتهي حلقتنا من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه جديده
فيما وراء اخذت من جديد
ام